[Music]
the cold isolation of space nowhere to
run and nowhere to hide aliens stalk the
halls with only one thing on their minds
expand and consume
keep watching to see how each alien
movie connects to one another
in the late 1970s hr giger designed a
new horrific movie monster the xenomorph
it became iconic for its lethal serrated
tail its flesh tearing proboscis and
acidic blood that could burn through the
hull of a spaceship
director ridley scott took giga's
creature and placed it inside the
nostromo a futuristic yet claustrophobic
spaceship that becomes little more than
a tomb for the xenomorph's many victims
upon its 1979 premiere alien cemented
itself as a sci-fi horror phenomenon
with sigourney weavers ellen ripley
enduring as one of the most iconic
protagonists in cinematic history in the
years since the alien universe has
developed a massive legacy steeped in
expansive law
i think they want us to come and find
them
[Music]
while prometheus was also helmed by
scots this prequel was a markedly
different experience than the original
movie the film follows dr elizabeth shaw
played by noumi reports and dr charlie
holloway portrayed by logan marshall
green as they tried to answer humanity's
big question where do we come from the
two archaeologists discover evidence
across multiple cultures and time
periods suggesting that humans
worshipped giant mysterious beings this
evidence also suggests an unknown
importance surrounding the distant moon
lv223 funded by the weyland corporation
the pair embark on a two-year journey
into space aboard the starship
prometheus the crew is eventually
awakened from stasis by the android
david played by michael fassbender upon
landing they discover impressive
technology years beyond humanity along
with vases of dark unidentified goom
while studying what they found several
crew members are attacked and infected
by alien lifeforms simultaneously david
experiments on other crew members using
the newfound goo but the real kicker
comes from the head of one of those
large humanoid beings depicted on earth
the species has given the moniker the
engineers
after doctors holloway and shore are
intimate with one another they come to
realize holloway is infected with an
alien contagion leading to his premature
death at the hands of the crew still
reeling from holloway's demise the croon
soon discovers they've been transporting
the withered peter weyland played by guy
pierce so that he could discover the key
to immortality to this end weyland and
david locate a living engineer in stasis
and awaken it while weyland is convinced
the engineer species were the original
craters of humanity and his source of
salvation the engineer ultimately kills
him decapitates david and is hell-bent
on tracking down the remaining crew dr
shaw learns that she is pregnant with an
alien life form and manages to extract
the octopus-like creature from her
abdomen through this she deduces that
the goo found on the moon was created by
the engineers to wipe out humanity after
shaw bessie engineer she takes david's
still active head and commandeers are
shipped to find the engineer's home
world as prometheus concludes the
octopus-like monster which shaw had
unleashed on the engineer to provide her
escape is revealed to be a proto
facehugger it implants the engineer with
a chest-bursting embryo similar to the
xenomorphs setting the stage for the
rest of the franchise
they are a dying species grasping for
resurrection
they don't deserve to start again and
i'm not going to let them
nearly 11 years after the events of
prometheus a solar flare damages the
colonization ship covenant while it's on
route to its designated planet the
android walter played by michael
fassbender awakens the emergency crew
only to have their captain perish due to
a technical malfunction upon repairing
the ship the covenant crew receives a
mysterious transmission which they trace
back to a nearby planet this setup kicks
off 2017's alien covenant scott's second
prequel the acting captain christopher
auram played by billy crudup decides to
settle on this new planet instead
while receiving pushback from chief
catherine daniels portrayed by catherine
waterstone aurum steers the covenant
towards the signal they discover the
engineer ship which dr shaw had stolen
in the final act of prometheus and after
trekking through the planet's wilderness
two of the crew are infected by airborne
spores the spores gestate into the newly
dubbed neomorphs which quickly grow into
adulthood and attack the crew amid the
chaos the prometheus android david comes
to their rescue
while the crew is initially trusting
they realize david has grown a god
complex through his years in isolation
it's revealed that he killed dr shaw to
experiment on her and systematically
wipe the engineer species from their
home world using the bio agent that had
been developed to kill humanity not only
that but david was the one who
engineered the genetic makeup of what
would become the xenomorph as aurum is
infected by a facehugger the remaining
crew make moves to immediately leave the
planet but when david destroys walter
and bores a covenant posing as him he's
followed by two xenomorphs who resume
terrorizing the chrome after the
xenomorphs are destroyed the remaining
crew enter hyper asleep to continue
their journey to their original
destination but as catherine enters her
pod she realizes in horror that david
has replaced walter and is now in
control of the ship while she falls into
stasis we see david placing the
xenomorph embryos in cold storage
setting up some of the groundwork for
the original 1979 film
this is ripley
last survivor of the nostromo
signing off
alien takes place 17 years after alien
covenant in the original landmark flick
we are introduced to the crew of the
nostromo as they come across a wayward
distress signal captain dallas played by
tom skerritt decides to investigate and
the crew discovers an alien ship bearing
a dead engineer and several alien eggs
after a facehugger emerges and attaches
itself to kane portrayed by john hurt
they break quarantine procedures and
bring their affected teammate back on
board the nostromo while the film
chronology confirms this as an engineer
ship the fact that the android david was
the final designer of the xenomorph
species leads to narrative
inconsistencies for the time between the
end of alien covenant and the start of
the original movie there are no
explanations as to how another engineer
ship came to contain a species that
wasn't created by them with an alien tv
series reportedly on the way and ridley
scott indicating another film is in the
works it's possible the gap will be
bridged in future installments
while the crew fails to safely remove
the facehugger from kane it's implants a
xenomorph embryo down his gullet after
he wakes and joins his shipmates for a
meal the hidden parasite to burst from
his chest cavity shocking the rest of
the crew before scurrying off as they
hunt for the creature it grows rapidly
and starts picking off members of the
team one by one the science officer ash
played by ian holm is discovered to be
an android task for the preservation of
the xenomorph for further study
regardless of the human passenger safety
after ripley sets the ship to
self-destruct and flees in an escape pod
she has one final showdown with the
xenomorph which ends in her blasting it
into space using the pod's exhaust from
there she sets a course for earth and
falls back into hypersleep alien's major
conflict has less to do with the deadly
alien aboard the nostromo and more to do
with a shadowy corporation using
whatever means to achieve their goals
however exactly how the weyland
corporation discovered the xenomorph's
location prior to our main cast finding
the derelict ship remains a mystery
ma'am i already said that it was not
indigenous it was a derelict spacecraft
it was an alien ship it was not from
there
at the start of james cameron's sequel
aliens ripley wakes up on a space
station orbiting earth after 57 years in
stasis she is debriefed by the weyland
yutani corporation who objectively
dismiss her explanation of what happened
in the previous movie however the
weyland yutani representative carter
burke played by paul reiser informed
ripley that they lost contact with the
terraforming colony at least hope he
convinces her to join a mission in which
they will determine the colony's fate as
well as destroy any alien species alive
on the planet upon their arrival the
colonial marines discover a young girl
named newt portrayed by carrie hen and
the rest of the population cocooned in
unrecognizable goo with chess bursters
popping from these trapped victims and
adult aliens attacking the team ripley
realizes that the xenomorphs are using
humans as incubators as attacks continue
the question becomes how are the eggs
being created ripley soon uncovers how
burke had ordered the colonists to
investigate the derelict engineer ship
still in orbit so that weyland yutani
could use the species for weapons
research ultimately ripley newt the
android bishop played by lance henriksen
and corporal hicks played by michael
bean are the only survivors the aliens
target newt after she is separated from
ripley who then pursues them into the
heart of their hive and finds a
xenomorph queen after reclaiming nudes
and escaping the queen they board a ship
to leave the planetoid behind but the
queen manages to get aboard ripley
battles a monster via a mechanical exo
suit and forces it out of an airlock the
survivors then enter hypersleep for a
trip back to earth and credits roll this
is ripley
last survivor of the nest drama
signing off
david fincher's 1992 film alien 3 begins
directly after the event of the previous
installments a mysterious fire on
ripley's ship forces a computer to
launch its escape pods onto the planet
fiorina 161
after ripley is recovered by dr clemens
played by charles dance she is brought
to an all-male maximum security prison
she learns that newton hicks were killed
in the spaceship crash while also being
informed that a message was sent to
weyland yutani for them to come and
collect her and certain of what caused a
fire on her ship ripley convinces
clemens to autopsy newt's body however
when a prison inmate dies under strange
circumstances she suspects that another
xenomorph managed to board her ship and
is now loose in the prison when ripley
finds and reactivates bishop he confirms
her fears of a rogue xenomorph just as
it ramps up its attacks on inmates but
since the prison lacks any kind of
weapon stockpile the remaining prisoners
must lure the alien into a death trap as
they work to put their plan into motion
ripley finds out that she is a current
incubator for a new xenomorph queen she
realizes she must kill herself but not
before helping the prison crew stop the
alien knowing it won't hurt her because
she's pregnant ripley and the remaining
crew corner the alien dump molten lead
on it call it with the emergency
sprinkler system and shatter the
creature to pieces upon their victory
however weyland-yutani arrives they try
to convince ripley that they can safely
remove the gestating queen from her body
but she doesn't buy it for an instant
she jumps into a massive blast furnace
killing herself and the queen also it
seemed
jean-pierre junai's 1997 follow-up alien
resurrection depicts the final
chronological events in the alien film
saga especially since ridley scott
declared the alien vs predator movies
non-canonical this installment
originally penned by joss whedon takes a
jurassic world approach to its story it
depicts the united system's ill-advised
attempt to clone the xenomorphs some 200
years after the events of alien 3.
utilizing ripley's dna the usm creates
clones of her with the alien queen
embryo still inside following seven
unsuccessful attempts they finally
create ripley eight who possesses the
original ellen ripley's genetic memories
additionally since her dna was grafted
with that of the xenomorph queen the
queen also shares the same genetic
knowledge as her host making them both
partial hybrids of each other when a
ragtag mercenary ship called the betty
arrives and delivers humans to service
hosts for alien embryos you can almost
hear ian malcolm's voice in jurassic
park stammering that life will find a
way while these human sacrifices do
indeed produce aliens the newest spawns
use their new genetic knowledge to break
free of their containment the aliens
proceed to attack the remaining soldiers
left on board and after a burst of
bloody mayhem only a few survivors
remain by this point ripley 8 has
discovered her own superhuman strength
and acidic blood in the meantime the
survivors find out that the station is
on autopilot and heading for earth
seeing the looming catastrophe in front
of them the team moves to escape via the
betty and destroy the usm station but
before they can all get to their life
raft ripley 8 is abducted by a xenomorph
and take him back to the hive it's
revealed to her that the alien queen has
evolved to possess a human-like
reproductive system and she gives birth
to a fully fledged human alien hybrid
when ripley 8 manages to escape the
xenomorph swarm and board sebetti with
the rest of the crew an open hatch
prevents them from leaving as they move
to fix the issue the human alien hybrid
attacks ripley 8 stops the creature by
using its genetic trust in her against
it while hugging the hybrid she creates
a hole in a nearby window using her
acidic blood which violently sucks the
creature into space the movie concludes
with the remaining crew arriving on
earth optimistic for a future without
the threat of a xenomorph apocalypse
well at least for now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you